today's topic we got banned off Tick
Tock so a month ago we were on Tick Tock
for nothing but 30 seconds yes a month
ago
um YouTube announced the whole thing
with the shorts so I figured you know
what it would be a good time to
capitalize I feel like our stuff can do
decent in short form but hired somebody
they're very talented
um I'll put a link in the bio for the
individual in question who runs the
stuff uh he's really good uh he's
picking out clips for stuff to put up on
uh Tick Tock and it blew up really fast
one of them reaching like four million
views it was trending and that video in
question Got Us Parma band and I want
you guys to see it first before doing
this
I don't even care for platform I don't
have the app I don't spend time on that
I don't do nothing with it I just
thought you know if I can run people
some money and then they run and they
grow it organically great to me the app
already on in space for what I can see
from the outside my limited
understanding is it's very left-leaning
liberal like you know very PC oriented
okay not my cup of tea not where I
normally want to spend my time because I
don't even feel like I'd survive on the
planet that's from the outside look at
it I could be wrong maybe you guys feel
differently I'm gonna play for you guys
to clip that got Tick Tock so upset and
you guys tell me what you think okay so
this is a tick tock okay and I want you
guys to hear this would you date a trans
person no no honestly think about it for
a second no
okay got your answer no no
I didn't need a second thank you well if
you said no I'm sorry but that's pretty
discriminatory I'm done
where are you going there's no
discrimination what I said I wouldn't
date a person that has a penis well it's
an old ass video okay and they didn't
even have the best part of that which
was because after that part you asked me
what about jalapenos because they got
everything taken off oh that's different
and I said well she can't have babies uh
she don't have a menstrual cycle
that's a perfect woman okay but even if
they used to have a penis oh mine to me
that's not a strand that's a woman
one plus
in some some situation
actually
hey we made a joke about that like yo I
don't give a [ __ ] like you didn't give
it up I don't give a [ __ ] go live it in
the comments bro I'm like periods do so
she ain't got no beers she can't she
can't fall pregnant I mean
they actually beat women on that
Americans what you want me to say
[Music]
what's funny thing so it of course no
you can't you can't even go and attack
the transphobic thing on it because I
was like Nabi yeah and here's the thing
dating is discriminatory people
discriminate against people who are
short people the way that she says
discriminatory though you got to
understand the insinuation she's saying
it like you're doing something that's
incredibly unethical or you're doing
something that's bigoted okay mind you
if you don't want to date someone from
particular culture you want to date
somebody from a particular height or
whatever it is you're free to do so
you're free to do so it's your dating
preferences but people trying to
guilt-trip other folks into being open
to dating certain things is so [ __ ]
cringe to me move on with your day
somebody's not interested who cares but
you running around saying you're a bad
person because you're not open to dating
people
I would laugh at a short person who said
something similar or somebody what
nobody if they're not interested move on
so that's my thoughts on that go ahead
if you if you ask the question what's
your type and you answer that question
whatever the hell your type is you're
discriminating against the people that
are not your type even if you answer the
question what's your type and your
answer is I don't have a type
now what about the people that are not
bad [ __ ] you're discriminating
against them too true so it's dating it
it is
what I'm good [ __ ] you got bad
[ __ ] what about the good ones there's
some good [ __ ] out there what's the
time of that you just tell they don't
suck properly
why would you discriminate against them
there's no dumb questions they got other
other attributes you know they're
punctual
yeah they arrive on time yeah arrive on
time to not suck Okay so
this is the video that gets us back
yes I'm not surprised of course not
what I do think is fascinating is even
just that is enough
so you have to imagine what the platform
is like and this is what Young Folks are
ingesting every single day now it could
be that I'm wrong and that there's much
more diversity on the platform in terms
of content in terms of conservative
ideas or whatever it is to me it's not
even that because if you ask most people
to be it left or right they're gonna say
no I ain't open to it the more the most
conservative thing that's on this
platform is so blurred out oh yeah you
guess it's unwatchable and it's not just
us I watch even like some left-leaning
political commentators like it seems
like anytime you get any type of like in
the center you don't even have to go on
the other side if you're in the center
it's off yeah and we appealed it and
it's been an appeals process for three
weeks now normally takes about one 72
hours to one week maximum so I think
they're just gonna leave us in purgatory
we did start another page so you guys
can go check it out we're gonna
re-upload it and let's see how long it
lasts so if you guys want to go check it
out we posted a bunch of other stuff so
I'll put a link in the description box
blow it up blow it up why because I want
to just see if to talk don't respond to
anything let's make let's make a yeah
social uh
experiment was that post the other part
why I say out of context well I say
trying to be one of the best people
because you know they're better than a
woman I see how that one is okay
I don't think that one's gonna pass not
yeah
I think I think the full context of the
whole clip is decent I think when you
put that thing
yeah because then we know they have a
problem with [ __ ]
all right listen listen I just think
this is what young people are ingesting
every single day so you can already see
the way in which social media is like
gonna shape the political landscape so
I'm curious to see what that's going to
look like in the future going forward
yeah we had a lot of people upset about
that video which is an old one and I
stand by what I said for the most part
you know maybe I got better
understanding certain Concepts but so
yeah motherfucker's not open to it move
on it's okay
and I think we had a good point which is
because people who always say to go big
for you to understand like if you
disagree most of the time when people
when you disagree with people they think
it's because you don't understand you
know I just don't agree with you which
is fine okay and whenever you disappear
to that point they go well what about if
someone will tell you they don't want to
date black people and we said that in
that video and we went okay
yeah
go ahead and be great
here's another fact some people claim
they're not discriminatory but then
their dating practices are oh yeah I'd
open a date everybody you look at her 10
x's and they look like the same the same
person if you don't get the [ __ ] up out
of here okay version listen it's fine
people have their preferences be it
cultural aesthetically pleasing what
they find endearing maybe it's due to
Childhood trauma means whatever who
knows why but they're still entitled to
those reasons to make those decisions
and it's not on you to sit there and
start telling people that you were upset
or you think it's just
mind your business move on go date
somewhere else
go where you're appreciated not where
your
your guilt-tripping people to
I was gonna do the whole goal where you
appreciate it not not tolerated but yeah
anyways you get the point I yeah yeah so
that's all I really got anything else
you want Tick Tock off no the greatest
platform on Earth no all right let us
know what you guys think
all right